I forgot Coolio died Coolio died
Coolio no
here lies Coolio
worst show of all time dude here lies
Coolio
hello
[Music]
what do you think about it we're live
what do you think about
uh worst interview are movies yeah that
the main character is boring and it's
supposed to be boring give me an example
because I I can't Sully
oh well Sully it's interesting to bring
up Sully because Sully is an example of
the worst movie interesting that there
is but Tom Hanks is very good in it I
honestly I love Tom Hanks but I don't
even think that about that movie I think
Clint Eastwood is the most boring
filmmaker oh he made that alive he's
basically not alive that's why he's
right so boring uh he tries to hurry
through the days he's like I love that
we did one take whatever the script is
fine as it is he doesn't do any rewrites
ever he's just a lady
boy a lazy boy
he's a lazy boy okay so there's a movie
about it's called the neighbor it's with
William Forsyth is that his name I mean
that's the name of an actor sure yeah
the guy who's in wasn't he like in wings
or something was that him no wait oh no
no no no no no no that's not William
Forsyth is the guy Stephen Weber no I
was thinking no no I was I know Stephen
Weber's in wings but I thought that
was
the bad guy in that movie with uh
uh
Ben Affleck
Oh no you're thinking thinkner that's
who I'm thinking about he's great I love
him yes he's great so he was in the
neighbor
and
what is the neighbor who's Forsyth
William Forsyth is like uh he was way
bigger in like the 90s yeah he's got a
real tough guy voice and look so thinker
or whatever
yeah William fichtner yeah okay so
fickner was a fickner says what a
fickner says what oh Forsyth is awesome
yeah yeah okay fickner is good he's in
the movie called the neighbor and he
plays a very boring guy but very boring
weird guy and it's arguable that the
movie is boring because of it well that
sounds about right when you have a lead
character and you're trying to make him
born the thing here's the thing when
you're depicting a boring person yeah
you don't need to be boring I know so
how do you make it good it's so cool I
took a mint and it made my my throat dry
now I'm coughing yeah dude [__] yeah wow
podcast well that was your fault you
should have taken a minute or I wanted
to do it
what I didn't mean to do that like that
I didn't know it was going to dry my
throat out did you no do you think a
mint always tries to throw it out no a
magician
no I didn't think that all right well
look all I'm gonna say is I'm gonna be
in Cleveland I'm gonna be in Pittsburgh
I'm going to be in Philadelphia I'm
going to be in Virginia chrisley.com
reading pitch Redding uh Pennsylvania
Ottawa Ontario too that's the only one
in Canada that's not sold out yet uh
Orlando Florida Fort Myers Florida and
Baltimore Maryland christelia.com to get
your tickets
um leave a uh comment for us oh actually
if you want to sign up for Lifeline
luxury that's where it's on and pop and
that's where it's going that's where
it's on firing on all
of the you know we say syllables but
cylinders really for Lifeline luxury uh
patreon.com Lifeline luxury that is a
show that comes out at least twice a
month and it is at least 30 minutes and
we absolutely kill it on there and go
over to our patreon And subscribe it is
it's going like this
what of what the quality of Lifetime
luxury is going like this way up oh okay
good well that's why we call Lifeline
luxury so go on there and get that and
uh go to uh watch lifeline.com to send
in your submissions we love your
submissions and then also you could send
us a video or click the link in the
hotline below or you can go and get a
one-on-one session with matalia on Zoom
where he gives you all sorts of devices
at matdalia.com and you can also get the
merch at lifelinemerch.com showing the
support of our show the greatest show in
all history and the show that keeps on
going like this which is what Matt is
saying right well I mean did so much
coke the mint the mint that you took
yeah yeah is really kicking in right
about now yeah so that's what's going on
my baby so we're having a good time you
know and you think it's okay to make a
show a movie about a boring person yeah
what about this if you make a movie
about a boring person make it be only an
hour and 20 minutes yeah but also you
can make a good an exciting movie about
that centers around a boring person you
don't need the movie itself to be boring
boring people getting caught up in very
not boring things it's actually really
interesting that is very interesting
it's like one of my favorite kinds of
movies so maybe that movie was just
boring it sounds like it sounds like it
and and not not to really anybody's
fault but like fickner is very he was
very good in it he's amazing yeah he's a
good I've always liked him he's in heat
your favorite movie he is in heat right
yeah and then the lady in it is good
really good too
um who's the lady who's the lady in it
uh uh in the movie The Neighbor the
she's very good in it too uh the the one
that the the younger lady that he kind
of like gets obsessed with what's her
name Jessica
I was already on there scrolled it off
do it bigger do it bigger
there it is crazy you didn't zoom in
crazy absolutely nuts hey absolutely
nuts scroll up absolutely nothing to me
macnami Jessica he's good she's good
anyway it's cool because it sounds like
Jessica
isn't it what is this oh thank you for
me who else would it be for he put it
right in front of you but I didn't ask
for you that's why but so there's two of
us and he handed it to one of us that's
you I thought maybe you asked for tea
but why wouldn't he give it to me it was
scratchy you made me TN that's very nice
that's really good now it's too hot so I
have to wait
I need to talk in it English one thing I
want to talk about drinking tea drinking
tea I'm the British
uh so we don't have our Tweety Bird
shirts yet It's upsetting So It's
upsetting because but we do still have
oh God two hats is the worst
two hats two hats no two hats to hold
two hats to hold the worst song of all
time it's not is that what else did you
want to say was that a takeoff of the
Coolio song Too Hot yeah yeah which is
actually a takeoff of an older song so
yeah music history Julio is an actor now
how about that
oh well he was an actor before he died
did you know that I forgot Coolio died
Coolio died
Coolio
no here lies Coolio
worst show of all time dude here lies
Coolio
and then and then so many people keep
getting out of his coffin like that
whole video
was the man do you know where they do
come on yeah
what was that though why do they look
out around way too much in that video
because they're like trying to make sure
nobody sees them yeah but so many yeah
you gotta be careful dude that was the
original version of staying woke that's
what it meant you got to be alert got to
pay attention no dude you know how
annoying is it that they stole that
I mean it's like the ultimate it's like
everybody always talks about cultural
appropriation it's like the ultimate
cultural appropriation oh yeah you know
oh my God blue your mind dude
that's absolutely unbelievable man so we
can't both be wearing sunglasses did you
know that oh
oh I was gonna take off mine okay
I guess one of us can and I'll keep
going I'll keep going
on a Fantastic Voyage
rights Liberty slide yeah that you're
talking about yeah that's the one yeah
they keep coming out of the thing
yeah mute it mute it
okay
skip to the end yeah well he doesn't
know where it is dude he's [__] 14
years old 12 years old
she passed it
look good dude there's yeah
and it was a very pretty they keep doing
it all right right I knew that oh dude
popping it dude when I was young and
these videos would come on I would get
so sexually around really yeah not me
dude look at all these amazingly
beautiful black women in the car dude I
was just 12 and I was just like right
slippery slide you know what I'm saying
hey
wow you can't be nuts a [__] drink it's
too hot hot well obviously too hot all
right so anyway
make it that hot why do I want to wait
for it no because you gotta heat up the
tea leaves enough to make it taste
better and which is therein lies why
it's [__] therein lies the
bullshitery yeah that's why it's
[__] dude it should only be as hot
as it it doesn't work figure out how it
works make it so the tea gets out when
it's not that hot okay but I mean like
you're so annoying you know all that
happens is exactly you something bad
happening you so you're like now the
whole thing's the whole Enterprise of
tea sucks yeah and that's how it is like
that's just not a good way of being
alive but it's just what's crazy is that
it's lasted for the song and everyone's
been burning their tongue on it for
[__] centuries you know what I mean
centuries
most people know to wait a minute I wait
but you still have to do the test and
every now and then you do the test too
early and it burns your [__] time oh
when you pull up
and then you do it you didn't do that I
don't
no it's just I don't then I might as
well go to Benihana and [__] help him
make the [__] I don't want bring it to
me when it's ready dude I'm right about
this yes
foreign
I agree with me
that's the dumbest thing you say a lot
of dumb things but when you say I agree
with me that's the dumbest
I don't know man go on over to sign the
lifeline luxury uh uh patreon.com
uh and we there's a little bit more
there's more of that but we're gonna get
into this show right now yeah because
it's been 10 minutes okay so let's go
yeah it's been too long so we're gonna
get into the devices here we go
love you both so handsome so I need
advice on a guy who lives at my
apartment complex we all have designated
parking spots yeah and the guy who parks
next to me just cannot seem to [__]
Park in his own spot and every time I
come home he's like right on the line or
in my parking spot then I got to be the
[__] who Parks too close to the guy
next to me that is bad and it's just
yeah that's a non-confrontational way I
can just be like yo learn to park you
know yeah and also Chris as a bar
employee thank you for spreading
Awareness on those [__] that
come in and sit down and then go to the
restroom right away like Hey Jill let me
get your drinks man
love you boys yeah I do I hate that you
know what he's talking about no I don't
like when dude go sit down order and
then go to the bathroom don't sit down
go to the bathroom and then comment
order and leave everybody and leave
everybody [__] waiting like oh you
didn't mention with a group you didn't
say that
yeah I guess I guess yeah personally
with a group yeah I was picturing a
person alone but he what he's saying
from on his end can be as a bar guy yeah
order first then go to that which is it
which is a similar complaint but it has
nothing to do with having a group it's
like right let me do my job and then you
go to the bathroom which I I do agree
with also ah go to the bathroom whatever
you want well his version doesn't matter
as much my version is is inconsiderate
if you do it that way gee what a
surprise that you think that let it let
everyone order then go to the bathroom
why would I would have wait what you
don't have to go to bathroom immediately
order unless you do if you do okay okay
but so you make exceptions for people
that are like ah I gotta go I gotta go
yeah you gotta go I gotta go unload
poopy out of my poopy hole then it's
okay I mean that's I would never have a
friend that says that but actually no we
know me and I would but yeah you would
but I would say that absolutely
you sit down with with eight people
okay that's so many people wow I hate
sitting now with apis oh my God okay for
you this
other person that's better now we're
speaking my language yeah and you sit
and you go get the menus and you're like
this
you know what I'm gonna go to the
bathroom who does this I don't are you
kidding me I don't approve Kristen oh
okay I see where this is and also so
many people and also others okay dude
Sam does it my videographer guy oh come
on Sam uh you know people just do it
dude yeah I'll order anyway but you
can't do it with Kristen that's the
thing because you need to be chivalrous
yeah right well that would be it's
another dude who cares I'm ordering he
went to take a thing I'm going to [__]
it I want the club sandwich go you
whenever he gets back right okay yeah
okay I get it and people think I'm the
dick I get it now what was his thing
again oh parking yeah yeah uh Park a
little bit in his spot next time if yeah
um and then what he confronts you say oh
I'm sorry was that annoying and then
when he starts to answer you say I know
you do it all the time so now you're
gonna stop so
[__] confrontation but that's good
here's the deal and this sucks
unfortunately because some people are
really anti-confrontation but
with people that live in your building
or in your yeah you gotta be careful no
you got to be aggressive now be
aggressive you got to be aggressive
because
it's never gonna work out we gotta be
careful if you don't of course well you
don't want to be like
with Sam Jackson and Josh Lucas or
whatever not Josh Lucas uh the other
Patrick uh Patrick Wilson yeah Lakeview
Terrace yeah that's a Neil the Butte
movie I like that movie it's weird
though I like it good I like that yeah
you got to be careful right
because you have to be careful but you
don't do things that are just gonna get
you killed you're just very direct and a
little bit louder than you usually are
that's all you got to do you're parking
back okay let's watch it yeah well that
wouldn't work out very well because then
you get arrested
but just get a little bit louder and be
firm you know a guy Richie movie
all right it got a park [__] way
different mate parking is the name of it
um if you don't you're gonna get [__]
a bunch of shots hanging [__] down
yeah so yeah just do what he does then
when he calls you out on it say oh yeah
you don't like that huh tarded no I
didn't think you liked that but guess
what you do it to me all the time so
guess what you're gonna do you're gonna
stop
Boston dude I am not sure you should do
that I think it's a very obvious answer
is simply walk up to somebody and say
hey man you park really close to me it's
really hard for me to get out and I
often have to park over to the right or
whatever left and then the other guy
can't get in and out could you just be a
little bit more mindful that's how you
have to start it okay if you that's easy
do that and that's easy and feel strong
about that if then it's still a problem
slash is tires but I'm dead serious oh
why what happened look oh well that
wasn't me yeah and they go like this
prove it with me oh okay it seems like a
really quick escalation and then I get
the video the CCTV footage and hits you
and you're like okay well okay never
mind okay well you proved it and now now
what now what do you want to be
red-handed but you didn't do the thing
yeah that sucks man having that kind of
a thing the parking that sucks because I
you know what
you know what sucks is you know what
sucks is is when you show up and
somebody is parked [__] up and you
can't get into space because of the
person and it's like the only parking
space that's there and you want to be
mad at that person but you don't know if
it's the person before them that made
them Park like that that's the worst I'm
surprised you think that far into it
because you're usually very rash and
very like quick on the draw of a of a
harsh hardcore reaction and that's not
good but this time you really thought it
all the way through I'm I've never been
more offended about anything you've said
why
I think very deeply about things that
don't matter yeah this does matter
uh okay and this is about extending sort
of an olive branch to other people
you're considering
other people's experience and that's
something you never really do I'm
offended okay I don't think that I I
don't think that that's correct I think
that if you knew me and you do know me
and that you know that I think very
deeply about this kind of stuff
that's the game dude that's game tax you
know what I'm talking about if somebody
go ah [__] that's game tax and you know
at least it works for me and my favorite
sometimes okay fine Nobody's Gonna Keep
Mike but then you wonder I hope people
understand that rule why are you saying
game tax because it's like you got to
charge it to the game that's just how
I got it you know I got it I got it yeah
it's all rough though well parking sucks
honestly we figured it out for you man
so I think every car should be exactly
the same it should be government funded
and you just get in and leave with
whatever cars are closest well that's a
good idea but be really hard and
honestly Chrysler Kia uh uh or just
every Cari Mercedes-Benz they'd all have
a big problem with that yeah so maybe
not because it affects our bottom line
okay and money is what makes a world go
run cool and that is smart to say that
and next
hey man Chris long time fan I love you
both I am calling in to tell you about
uh Jordan with the slam moment that I
had uh it's not a particular moment but
it's a friend I had his name was Andrew
he was the funniest dude I'd ever met I
knew him in Middle School in high school
he was never funny on purpose like
sometimes he was but he was mainly funny
because he was just funny like
he was just sleepy all the time he was
just like oh like life was getting the
best of it he was he was never high but
you know high all the time but he wasn't
saying so many things
the first one is the funniest thing
that's any that anyone's ever told me
and it was that one time when he got
McDonald's because he never ate fast
food he got McDonald's and it made him
so nauseous that he had to throw up so
he went to the bathroom and he spun
around in a circle until he threw up and
it worked uh the next thing
is one time in seventh grade he showed
up and his eye was really red and he was
like oh my eye and then as the day went
on his eye just got more and more [__]
and then like he was like oh like he
couldn't focus he couldn't do [__] and
then like last period I remember
something he was picking at his eye and
this GL like this glass Shard fell out
of his eyeball onto his desk and it was
his contact lens that he slept with for
three days in his eye and it just dried
up into a little crystallized shell and
then the third thing which is maybe the
funniest thing you could ever come up
with in the world but it was real
uh in seventh grade we had an Outsiders
day where you would come dresses the
characters from the book The Outsiders
for some reason and obviously no one was
going to dress as a soch so everyone
dressed as a greaser yeah he came with
his dad's giant leather jacket and for
some reason his mom thought it was a
good idea to put temporary hair dye in
his hair and he had hair like mine like
blonde
and by the end of the day he had sweat
so much that the black hair dye dripped
all over his face and he was a black
face
um and then it was all over his arms and
his shirt and his hands and it got all
over his desk and he had to stay
afterwards to clean it off but it
wouldn't come out uh so yeah that's my
friend Andrew thank you for listening
sorry if this was long I love you guys
thank you dude hold on okay so first of
all these are not Jordan with the slam
moments okay what the hell was that was
how was he even that's what we're
talking about confused at the top we're
talking about how yeah he we're talking
about simple things that happen in life
that you terms or phrases that you
say over and over again with your
friends I've been
misled by that man that man misled me
and whenever I read the word misled I
think it says maiseld and I need a
second to see that it actually says
misled okay
and it bothers me maisel dude I'm always
like what does miseled mean and then I'm
like oh oh oh I remember that I have a
brain this is misled but dude he misled
us he said John what the Slime yeah
he just told us about Andrew what he's
yeah he told us about his friend Andrew
and told us basically Andrew's
autobiography the the that guy sounds
like somebody that I would deeply be
friends yeah you would have honestly
known him since you were like 19. yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh so also he would die
at like 48 you know yeah dude yeah so
all right uh I don't uh what what do we
do great well there's no advice Andrew
sounds amazing no we asked people to
call in yes and tell us our Jordan with
the slam stories yeah and for those of
you that don't know what that is I
didn't see the episode we were talking
about this they're they're just moments
in your life that you think about all
the time yeah that you sh that you that
aren't really that significant right
that just stuck with you and there's and
then you have like sayings with your
friends and you joke around about them
in shorthand and that those three things
were absolutely not that they were funny
stories each one of the things he said
was let me break it down mathematically
for people out there who don't
understand other ways that was each one
was zero percent like Jordan what does
right right zero they were funny stories
yeah and he could think about them a lot
but those were not considered I don't
know what the Slime stories they were
not even close to being in the column of
Jordan
honestly what he did they were funny and
you keep I have things that I think
about story situations oh yeah but none
of them are I don't want the slang you
know what I mean if they're not Jordan
what the submit an entire video claiming
that they are in the category of Jordan
why would you do that I get it you
wanted to share about Andrew but it's
not gone
this is
the worst podcast you know but dude it's
so good it's so funny that these are
podcasts and then also Jordan Peterson
has one you know said it so fast
said it so fast so that guy Andrew
sounds like something I want Andrew to
call in honestly get Andrew to send you
a video and send a video to us because
that's amazing okay please do that also
either cut your hair you or figure start
a new way
shake this dude like this dude push it
you do it like this just do like this
dude push it back push it back either
your hair's not gonna come out
push it back push them back so you know
that one the soccer I mean it's all good
I'm not insecure I'm not insecure so um
anyway yeah just being all delicate
this one was the best like they're
antiques
condition
my hair is a king of Virginia rookie
card that's so stupid very cool the Drew
black hole die cut okay Drew bledso die
cut all right let's take a break look at
this guys football is back in full swing
football is back in full swing with
another week of Epic Games isn't that
right that's right who's got you covered
on the action for every single one of
them draftking Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NFL new
customers check this out can bet five
dollars on football and get you're
probably like what do we get you know we
have a 500 no you get 200 instantly in
bonus Betsy just bet five dollars on
football get two hundred dollars
instantly in bonus bets uh nobody's
missing out on the action this season
all DraftKings customers can take
advantage of two new offers every game
day this this September I just can't
believe it get in on the NFL week two
action that's when it really kicks in
week one is ah week two you're in full
swing with DraftKings Sportsbook
download the app now and use the code
Lifeline to sign up new customers can
bet just five dollars and take home 200
instantly in bonus bets only on
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Lifeline
the crown is yours so who you got my
guys always suck but I believe it on
this here the Jets that got Aaron
Rodgers baby and they're playing the
Cowboys come on Jets okay so you like
the Jets and that's who we're going for
the Cowboys in week two Okay cool so go
to DraftKings Sportsbook download the
app and you can use the code lifeline
and it uh everyone everyone's a winner
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler or
visit
www.1800gambler.net in New York call
1-877-8 Hope and why or text Hope and
why that's 46 73 69. in Connecticut help
is available for problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit ccpg.org please
play responsibly on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort Kansas 21 plus age
varies by jurisdiction
void in Ontario C
sportsbook.draftkicks.com football terms
for eligibility terms and responsible
gaming resources bonus bets expire seven
days after issuance eligibility and
deposit restrictions apply
hey guys I love the podcast wow
um very Collective to this person
my question is what how do you respond
to people that keep asking you to hang
out when like it's really the last thing
you want to do is to hang out with them
obviously if it was someone that you
didn't see very often you could like
brush it off but
I have people in my life at work and
like neighbors oh worse organically
often
oh that keep asking to hang out when
they just make me feel uncomfortable and
I don't have like a lot of free time on
my hands
so it's not really something I want to
do
so how do you respond to those people
um Beyond like let me check my schedule
or I'll get back to you every single
time thank you
oh you don't want to have too much I
have so much going on like I I I'll when
I free up I'll let you know
yeah but then yeah that dude man yeah I
know your neighbor dude that's honestly
you should never ask to hang out with
your neighbor the neighbor is actually
off limits and the fact that your
neighbors are asking you to hang out is
is step I mean One Step Beyond like okay
like that's beyond the threshold you're
not allowed to do that here's the thing
though
if it's not your neighbor and they're
just texting you here's what you got to
do and it's sad and it sucks but you
gotta not respond you just gotta not
respond the neighbor thing
you might ah neighbors are tricky though
especially if in her case if it's a man
you got to be careful because the he's
already yeah I'm leaning towards saying
he's a psychopath for asking you to hang
out in the first place because he's your
neighbor right not fully saying he's a
psychopath but like he's already doing
it wrong so you don't want to like right
Express he doesn't understand boundaries
yeah yeah and so when I want to hang out
sometime no
I just think oh man the neighbor one's
really hard that's really tough but you
might have to say something man you
might have to just be like
look I I just I think it's I've had
maybe maybe you lie and say I've had bad
experiences in the past becoming friends
with my neighbor oh yeah I'm just like I
don't think it's the best idea I love
how you're friendly I'm always gonna be
friendly to you but like I don't think
like hanging out is best that's so even
saying that sounds hard though I don't I
know I'm not even recommending that but
it might have to come to that yeah it
might have to come to that
I mean I you know or dude ignore the
[__] out of them like be be rude without
using yeah that might be the move be
rude without using your voice like hey
Adrian Adrian you know Adrian her name
no but I'm saying we don't call the
neighbor a wrong name yeah no then
definitely no I'm saying they're saying
to her hey no I don't know it might not
be it might be but okay so say her name
is Adrian okay hey Adrian Adrian oh God
and then Adrian just keeps on she keeps
on walking Adrian she keeps on walking
Adrian what hey it just keeps on walking
well that's pretty crazy but I think
that but whatever you gotta do what you
gotta do next thing you do when you move
you just whenever somebody says
something I don't speak English yeah
right yeah like that you gotta kinda
unfortunately especially if you're a
woman you gotta kind of I hate saying
this you got to kind of not be that nice
to your neighbors oh yeah that is true
it sucks man but it's true that is true
you really that is true
I've seen men get the wrong idea it's
just like what are you thinking you
dumbass biologically we have to get the
wrong idea you know it's true but like
men don't always take it the right way
when they realize they've gotten the
wrong idea right unlike me when I
realized I got the wrong idea the last
thing I want to do I'm so hip to like I
haven't gotten the whole idea oh my bad
forget it forget you ever saw me you
know what I mean he ever saw me I don't
exist uh that's so sad but I don't know
I'm nothing wipe your ass with me please
um but yeah some guys just don't take
kindly to that but whatever
I I feel for you you're in a tough spot
but if it's all if it's via text friends
yeah I agree with that the texting one
that's easier the neighbor thing's
harder but
if it comes to it just fully ignore them
and then if that doesn't work you go you
might just have to say look yeah lie and
say I've had a bad experience in the
past I don't I have rule I don't become
friends with my neighbors I'll always be
friendly with you though and I apologize
if that isn't what you want to hear but
like that's just that's a rule I've made
and I have to go buy it simple as that
you know nobody can argue with like past
bad experiences yeah there you go so
yeah
you're welcome okay next one
hey Kristen uh Matt forgot my name how
you doing it's uh coming at you from the
Grand Old State of Connecticut from
Grand average State I guess okay um my
question is uh it's kind of It kind of
applies to you more so Chris but Matt
would love your Insight
uh freshly new dad
um
and I'm losing a lot of sleep because of
the fear of when we put our baby to bed
oh no uh she could turn over maybe hurt
herself uh does this go away is there
any mental trick trick that I can you
know do to to help me sleep and put
peace of mind or does it get worse as to
get older and then they actually start
rolling over
all right well life rips before you go
let me just say one thing
I've heard this on Authority like from
doctors babies can't roll over or no
when babies are ready to roll over is
when they can handle being
something that has rolled over right so
like if your baby is rolling over they
can handle being on their stomachs until
that point you never want to put your
baby face down because they can't handle
it but if they're doing it on their own
they can handle it is what I understand
go ahead Calvin and Billy both only
slept on their stomach from infancy
right so on their stomach so
you're putting his mind at ease you're
saying right no yes right okay like he's
scared of them sleeping on their stomach
he is yeah Billy and Calvin both only
slept on their stomach and they're great
so well there you go yeah
I mean like I think that the betting
thing is the is the is the main thing
it's like just have only the cover of
the actual what do you call it yeah no
loose blankets yeah no loose blanketing
but
um we you know you you swaddle them all
up yeah they're like this
so I mean
yeah that I here's I think the grander
thing is you're just worried would
because you're in territory that you've
never experienced before with Calvin my
thing was oh God I don't want to feed
him or watch him eat because he he could
choke he's gonna choke he's just gonna
get every every when they start eating
every baby they start they choke and
they just work through it and I sitting
through oh god dude that was so so hard
for me
um specifically because you thought it
was a joke yeah okay so and that was my
thing right you know but do you realize
how
like unnecessary it was to worry like
that I do now yeah that I have Billy
because I'm worried away less way less
about everything although he hasn't
started eating hard food yet right so
maybe I still will be a little bit but
that was my thing
um you're just dealing with anxiety of
being a first-time dad and this is how
it's presenting itself nothing's gonna
happen to your baby when you're when
it's rolled over I mean yes yeah that's
like you know I mean I get SIDS is a
real thing so don't infant that but but
it usually isn't just from rolling over
SIDS yeah right exactly there's like a
what are they called cats Runners on the
on the pads on the crib that that leads
to SIDS uh cats rarely why you saying
cats okay they go in and they steal
their breath
cats like felines felines run in and
they go and they they dip up over the
baby and they go
and they steal their breath a witch
doctor okay
okay yeah you have a cat be careful yeah
you're a new dad though it makes sense
that you'd be worried about this and
that and you know it's all gonna like
anything else that people are new at
what you're worried about is gonna get
less and less as time goes on which you
realize how much everything's actually
always okay yeah yeah do cats do some
like oh [__] no man hey man no do cats
steal baby's breath no no but I thought
maybe that would have been a problem the
the the fear is that the cat will curl
up next to the baby's mouth and
obviously but that's it that and so
that's what I was asking right but I'm
making a joke that they've don't do that
that they in fact
rob a baby's insides which is not what's
true so yeah yeah can't but that's 100
obvious cats can't do that dude is there
some sort of Truth or the cat baby's
breath no but they cut up again that's
what I'm trying to get I thought I heard
something like that the cat's still you
know what I did hear something that is a
Nicolas Cage movie
I know you're doing Michael I'm kidding
but like obviously yeah I know I know
I know I'm already falling out hacking
into my computer and blasting out n-word
tweets
um no we'll have a chat afterwards
[Laughter]
I'm not a fat guy
oh you failed to turn that on for us
okay
not me not me dude
make it hit me more
during one of the first few episodes
um about a friend who had bad breath and
Matt you recommended stabbing him and so
I stabbed him his breath got better but
I wanted to call him today because
I uh you guys have mentioned water
stores a few times in recent episodes
and I had I got to tell you my first job
in 10th grade was at a water store in a
suburb of Detroit and people would come
in and buy drinking water there and all
it was was like it was water from the
tap that went through this machine yeah
right
um it was called the alkalizer it was
like the size of like a toaster and it
would just make the pH a little bit
higher and people would come through and
buy it for like seven or eight dollars a
gallon whoa
um and he did you know the guy who owned
the store like peddled all these
benefits like it can cure cancer which
is wildly this water will cure cancer
it'll cure heart disease and cholesterol
issues and like all these things
two years after I left that job the guy
died
from freaking
heart issues like the thing he said his
water would cure and yeah I went out to
get a degree in biology and looking back
on that I think the whole thing for the
most part was pretty much a scam and so
um yeah anyway love you guys Chris can't
wait to see you in Nashville at the
Ryman Auditorium September 9th get your
tickets at chrisley.com Matt love you as
well see you guys soon dude why don't
people do that for me I don't have to do
it that's awesome what a great guy that
guy was that guy was a great guy sorry
we told you to stab your friend that guy
is a guy I would be friends with yeah he
I would too actually you know what dude
that guy seems like a total chill dude I
would hang out with yeah yeah like not
in the stole my thunder
you would hang out with me
[Laughter]
we want to be that guy's friend well
yeah but that no so here's the thing we
run into he may be crazy and I'm gonna
end up seeing him in Nashville so that's
the thing about that is you can say it
but be careful because he could end up
being like stabbing me like he did with
his friends he's known to stab people my
thing is I can say whatever I want and I
think he that guy that guy is one of my
best friends okay well how out of how
many
uh I think that uh that's crazy yeah but
here the thing about a water store
remember when they started bottling
water everyone was like this is a scam
what really I don't remember that yeah
it was like throw up uh
I when was it like it was in the 80s
I don't think they did that in the 70s
and [__] no no no right no no no no they
had they they have out of water before
that no I don't even think in the 80s
right right yeah it could be even be 90s
but I remember when they I have a memory
scam it's like it's convenience there's
no like well no because before that
people would just do it out of the tap
tap they said it's in 60. oh you're
saying okay I got you yeah yeah
yeah but they were like glass yeah yeah
yeah
1622 I mean what
just with a bottle of Arrowhead in the
70s it said yeah dude I know who Spinoza
is okay well I don't
Spinoza and leibniz just cheers in with
Dasani bottles all right man you know
yeah
yeah I remember one day in the heretic
just cheers I remember when there was a
an explosion of you know bottled water
and then
people were like what is this I just
drink it from the top I remember people
in my childhood being like nah just
drink the tap water yeah sure right and
now that's not even fathomable
people I mean I'm are now for different
reasons getting away from the bottle
because of right environmental stuff yes
which I understand that but
this thing is just like going to a store
where you buy your water I mean solely
seems like a step back it's a like it
seems like something in 16. it is a scam
like and also if you want your water to
be better balanced and in alkalizer get
yeah an alkalizer right but honestly who
is a girl who is alkalizer no dude no I
wanted to say it Go and drink your own
piss honestly but just do it through a
filtration system like Bear Grylls you
know there's a baseball player named
alkaline
this is baseball player named Albert
Pujols too and that is disgusting that
is but alkaline is there is really not a
Chris Berman alkaline
water he would do that but yeah he
definitely would yeah there's Albert
Pujols and when I told that I was like
you realize his last name is poo holes
he laughed and he said he didn't realize
it and I'm observing and Dad wasn't for
that yeah Dad you messed up did you ever
think about that for pool halls yeah
remember that big video game that him
and I used to play at the baseball game
where it had this really like dumb like
romanticizing baseball song okay like
like a Japanese thing no no like it was
very American like Heritage America oh
okay the heritage of baseball and like
it was very sweeping music that would
play I don't know that and you would
make up lyrics oh yes I do remember them
yes
I hate you you loved it yeah but you
asked me to do it no no no you would ask
me to do it okay do it now I don't
remember the tune it was um what was the
game yeah
I don't remember the game we can never
remember baseball video games the last
ones wait what Chris what music that
they used for that game was the theme
song to The Natural it was okay yeah
yeah it was
oh
so type in video game do theme song to
The Natural
that's it yeah this is n't right here
yeah let's see
we can't play it though
yeah oh you're right
I mean that's enough okay we gotta turn
it off because we'll get demonetized but
um what was the video game I wonder who
cares uh all right cool
shrooms Mario Luigi
okay all right watch out totally small
hey Chris Randy here
about an hour and a half southeast of
Montreal which is where I'll be seeing
you Chris on September 22nd Edition I
got meet and greet tickets been a fan
for a long time I'm so excited to meet
you but uh where I need advice is uh I
just started this side business where I
weld and make metal art repairs and
stuff like that okay I make some simple
stuff and some more interesting pieces
like flowers and things like that
tarantulas I guess I'm seeking advice on
how to confidently price my things and
stick to it because I'll work hard on
something somebody will be like I'm
interested how much I'll give them a
price they'll be like only that I'll
take it for sure I thought it'd be more
which means I lost out on a lot of money
that I think I deserve if I did the work
um so I I also worry about them being
like that's way too much it's kind of
like telling me that like they think
it's not worth it you're not good enough
it's not worth it it's a deeper I know
yeah but yeah so how do I just
confidently stick with it and be like it
is what it is because I want to make
sales but I don't want to work super
hard for like almost no profit you know
and before I go Chris if you want a
metal Rose for Kristen I'd be glad to
send that and if you want anything in
the world I'll build it for you so
thanks a lot guys hope you guys that's
so cute oh dude let me get a house I'm
making a house shout out to this guy
whatever maybe his thing is we have his
thing and if you want a medal put his
website on the screen um but you know I
there's two ways you can do this I
always think pricing something
with I'm a I'm a sucker so like if you
take a new brand okay I've never heard
of I walk in and it's five dollars why
I'm whatever it is okay I'm less likely
to buy it than if it's a hundred dollars
oh you're an idiot I know I'm a [__]
idiot because a lot of people are like
that I know and I and I am fully
admitting yeah I I am an idiot for this
what's good is that you're admitting it
most people are like that don't even
recognize I I I I I realize it's
happening too and I'm like I still want
it more yeah it's stupid it's I you know
what the calling you an idiot isn't fair
it's a very very much like a human thing
but it works that is common now listen
in terms of pricing things
don't price something that makes doing
the thing in the first place not worth
your time no well the other thing I was
going to say is
consider how much time you've put in
right put a price on the hour and then
make that the cost of the thing which is
why I was gonna say I'm not hijacked it
but yes I hijacked it yeah yeah yeah so
exactly what you're going to say exactly
what I was gonna say figure out an hour
wage for you yeah and how then calculate
how long it costs to make a thing deduce
the material thing exactly and then add
the materials as well you know cost of
doing business baby yeah but that's what
I think and then just honestly stick by
it dude and if someone says well I see
it's forty dollars but I'll give you 30
and if you want to do that then okay
right but don't don't back down from
figure out the price that's what the
price is and I think that that's cool
yeah and then if you of course as he's
saying if you want to bend for a certain
buyer or several then go for it you
don't need to be like an a dick about it
right but don't under price your stuff
just
he should know that also pricing
something perfectly in anything is like
one of the hardest things to do yeah
art dude someone will pay like yeah 10
grand for the dumbest looking painting
you ever saw it is weird dude because I
always argue with my uh tour guys I'm
like dude make my tickets less money I
want to have just more people come the
beginning I wanted to have a higher
price especially when I came back
because I only wanted my real fans to
come but now I'm like well maybe we
should lower the ticket prices because I
want to fill out I want to I want people
to be happy I want everyone selling out
what's the problem I know so
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
monetarily but I still feel like there
are people that won't come sometimes
because it's too expensive okay and that
makes me sad
what about that green paper though the
yaper I gotta stack it I get it yeah but
it's uh well one thing I've noticed too
is that people really do understand when
you put a premium on your own product
like I've had many people and I haven't
changed the price but I've had many
people be like you should definitely be
charging more for these I always said
you should and so from now on it's I'm
gonna charge a thousand dollars a minute
for the advice sessions but it's like
also you wanna you wanna you wanna
maximize your profit by let's say you
know the [__] Morgan Whalen may you
know sells tickets for a hundred dollars
and he sells
tens of thousands of tickets on his tour
or hundreds of thousands obviously
Millions even but um
and then you see he said he makes his
tickets five hundred dollars and he
sells way less but the profit is more
do you know what I'm saying yeah
constantly you're trying to figure and
then you're you're battling okay there's
another guy that people are coming to
see more if he's on you know he's the
new hot new musician or whatever the
[__] and it's like you you never really
know you're never gonna get that perfect
price point of this is the most money I
could have possibly made
I would guess I'm thinking about it too
too much now but no you're right that's
exactly the right things you just
started you know but um but yeah I I
just um I don't know I guess that's
hopefully that helps but don't don't
don't be insecure about it basically
it's my my main point
yes price what you want period give it
give every piece a price and that's the
price if someone asks specifically can I
I can't afford that can I do 10 whatever
you know sure but um
all right
upside down Chris you've got me through
some tough times Matt the other reason
Chris is hilarious so keep doing what
you're doing I have younger siblings and
we couldn't do without you that's cute
yes boys I had to get on here to talk
about these water stores growing up they
were all over my community yeah see I
asked my parents what's up with these
water stores they explained to me that
in second and third one countries you
can't rely on drinking water from the
tap so you had to go get your water yeah
delivered or go pick it up yourself I
try to explain to them you know in this
country the water districts have to go
through certain regulations uh they
don't trust it they refuse to drink oh
interesting they trust this water store
and these water stores take advantage of
the trust that these people have in them
so that's why there's a lot of them in
some of the yeah more urban communities
uh it's unfortunate but it's uh they
refuse to trust trap water so that's why
there's so many in urban communities
dude you are
a good person for expanding my mind
right now thank you I did not I never
would have guessed that well you know
that they take advantage of them of
course but the specific about immigrant
thing immigrants thing that I never ever
would have thought you think the store
owners are saying you know he's saying
they're exploiting immigrants because
they don't trust tap water from
experience in their own country I
understand that but do you think that
the store owners know that and pray on
that
The Immigrant I don't know if it's like
that's a predatory but no no that was a
strong word but I probably know yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because a lot of them are immigrants
themselves right very very good one
pound water they're like that very very
good one gallon water yeah like so so
it's not okay so because yeah because
you're not seeing those things in
Beverly Hills right no no no no no no
way no we don't get that [__] delivered
anyway yeah
interesting very very very interesting
okay thanks man
hi Chris and Max love the show yes I
know I'm bald anyway let's make this
quick because it's a long time in the
Netherlands I live in Australia
um to extend my one year Visa with
another year I have to do three months
of farm work for some reason which I'm
doing right now wow and it's all good
but two weeks ago the farmer sent me to
their parents place to work there for a
couple of days because they're trying to
sell the house and they can do it in
themselves I'm like sure I go there with
my own car
uh it's not my job you know it's not
farming but whatever I do this I don't
complain much and after these three days
the parents were Lovely by the way they
uh gave me a 750 tip on top of my wages
and I'm like I can't accept that that's
way too much but they refused to take it
back they said no you did a great job
we're gonna sell the house now here's
750 on there all right go back to the
farm I told this story because I'm an
honest guy he's gonna and they were like
oh yeah that's crazy that's too much but
uh then I noticed they took it out of my
way just without telling me
now 750 doesn't really oh my goodness
now these parents think that they gave
me a huge gift which their daughter
basically you know took and the daughter
told the parents that they would give it
to me which so now she's lying and I
just feel bad and it's not because of
the money but because of these lovely
old people think they gave me this huge
amount of money
and they didn't basically they just paid
me so I don't know what to do do I
tell the parents like hey they give this
is what happens their daughter and you
know maybe instigate a family fight
which I don't want to get fired because
a farm job is hard to find and if I
don't finish this then I can't stay in
Australia
or do I just you know Let it Go and yeah
I don't know because this is a weird
situation anyway
um love to hear from y'all like rips
awesome yeah ciao okay so he has to do
fun you don't understand I understand
that yeah he was working on This Woman's
Farm yeah she said uh my parents need
help yeah I'm getting I understand then
what are you asking I said the daughter
yeah the daughter you should know you're
pissing me off yeah but he went back to
work for the daughter after that told
the daughter and then she took the money
she kept no she she reduced seven she
took out 750 of his Bridges oh that's
crazy though it's completely crazy so I
think I totally understood once you're
done
don't say [__] you don't you can't
because you can't risk losing you don't
want to hear you yeah exactly you don't
want to give yourself that heck but why
did you tell the daughter I would have
never told the daughter right but I get
that because he's so honest yeah but
he's also so like probably so touched
swedes he's just like swedes just are
beautiful your parents are so sweet they
tip me so well like I can't believe it
and I told them no no but whatever I
guess Swede is almost sweet right okay
yeah but Swedish people are just on
another level man and they make great
films but go ahead okay let me finish
that uh wait till you're done then the
very day you're done or maybe there's
some paperwork that she needs to fill
out wait till all of it's done
get make sure you have the address of
where the parents went to afterwards
because I'm sure they'd share it with
you because they like you
immediately tell them once once the
whole book is closed on your farming
thing yeah your case closed tell them
and I don't know agree their daughter is
a piece of hot steaming Australia [__] I
don't agree with
that okay you gotta after everything's
done agree with that part you've got to
approach the daughter first and you got
to say yo that was messed up you gotta
give him my 750 back then if that
doesn't work then you go to the parents
is there any way this was a mistake no
way how how could that be a mistake
I mean I guess I guess he could have she
could have understood that oh they
charged him he charged her more or
something yeah I guess it could be she's
saying like I would I would be like
sorry did some is there I'm confused
there was a bonus here and then it was
just removed that's a way to approach it
if you're a normal person yeah but no if
it was a normal job in a normal
situation yes but he's in a situation
where he's an immigrant and wants to
extend his visa and doesn't want to
jeopardize his three-month thing what
I'm saying that thing after the
three-month Bank he could set up yeah he
could yeah if you want to be a normal
person yeah but who wants to be a normal
person you go when 750 is on the line
you want to be a normal person but if
all you want is a 750 you go back to the
you get the girl in trouble no dude no
snitching man you go back to this person
with no snitching but all bets are off
with this [__] who's not given this
who's literally she took 700 away from
this pork except for Marco's right it
could be a misunderstanding it could
example it's probably he could she could
have understood it as when he told her
oh this is what
he charged instead yeah they they
overpaid him they overpaid it's it's she
thought it should be the companies what
about the fact that he only ever used
the word tip if yes that is that is most
likely what happened why are we being so
generous to this because you have to be
an [__] because you have you've only
heard him talk you don't know the what
she thought you don't know she
but she could also just be a [__]
[__] no I don't think it's criminal or
[__] what I think is she thinks he took
advantage of her parents that okay and
doesn't deserve that that's not her
[__] call that's why it makes me so
mad but that's you still have to go to
her though but she's taking the okay
fine but she's taking the agency away
from her parents and that's what pisses
me off the most okay she's basically
saying
they're not allowed to tip you that I'm
deciding now out of my [__] wages
that I'm paying you to not give them to
you stop it
what's happening it's a deeper went
through this room
yeah I mean I don't know I I
either way you gotta approach her first
because this whole thing about
snitching is [__] you you can if she
says no go [__] yourself then you tell
the parents well she here's the thing
why I don't like you don't just too many
steps yeah but you need to give people
the benefit of the doubt on their
intention I don't think so she's
mistreating a [__] immigrant who has
no recourse that's [__] up if she's
intentionally doing that yes you think
she's possibly making an error wow it is
so generous it is that it's such a
generous reading of the situation it is
possible I don't believe that's what's
happening
but it's possible I think this guy's
probably spot on it's possible there's a
[__] sausage in my ass right now but
there isn't and I don't have to check
you know what I'm saying no you would
feel it a hundred percent and know 100
maybe somebody numbed my butt this is
less about giving her the benefit of the
doubt and just as a path to sort of
resolving this or at least confronting
it in a very diplomatic way he's right
yeah he's right just be like I'm sorry
was there a confusion and it would also
force her to put into words what she did
or what she was thinking she's like yeah
yeah you didn't deserve that or I don't
know yeah I like what he said better
than what you said okay they don't want
to give it to you it was my insurance
money just give it to me and then in the
event that she's like yeah we actually
can't afford to pay you or whatever
[__] reason is that you would then
just respond with oh okay and and be
cool as a cucumber so you're not
jeopardizing your job or risking
anything that's what I think you also
want to hear her side of the story don't
you wouldn't you I would I don't think
you're for sure risking your job just by
asking no but you could also wait no
harm no yeah what's the point he even
said himself 700 isn't that much of a
big deal like that that to me is the
main a primary thing the fact that the
money is meaningless to him is an
important part of the story like he's
not in need of that 750 and so
it's not about the money even a little
bit all in fact I bet he doesn't even
care if he gets it it's all about this
in his mind stay there this piece of
[__] woman oh I know obviously yeah make
sure again make sure you see it all the
way through and only do any of this once
everything's completely done and your
immigration your Visa is extended but
dude that is that is makes me mad if
that's 100 what happened then that's
infuriating yeah that's terrible yeah
yeah you know and and it sounds like
that is what happens yeah yeah right
yeah but like if it were me in that
situation I would just want to I would
have to understand I would I would ask
that woman what about it because I want
to know what's going on in her head the
fact that she would do that and not say
anything is astounding to me dude what a
[__] [__] unless she misunderstood
but which is not probable
right
okay I'm pissed yeah I'm pissed
I'm piscus what I'm saying is valid and
I'm pissed okay and you need to
understand that okay I do okay so yes
I'll be in Cleveland and yes I'll be in
Pittsburgh and Philadelphia and all that
stuff and Virginia and Baltimore
chrysler.com patreon.com Lifeline luxury
for our Lifeline luxury shows
um and uh you gotta go check those out
there's a bunch of them now that we have
on there if you go sign up now you can
listen all the backgrounds yeah
um and uh if you have a question go to
watch lifeline.com or message us on the
hotline all Below in the description and
I got the merchant lifelinemerch.com
leave a message leave a comment
subscribe and uh you know you want to be
a one-on-one with me you want a private
beautiful session make your life better
make your life much better you go to
magically.com and book it with me
and that's that that's that
[Music]